how do you say thank you i'm a second
hello it was longer than i thought
hi i'm ria hi i'm mimo today mimo is
going to teach me her favorite food
gronina from ethiopia the catch is
i have no idea so that's amharic this is
a mark one of the languages in ethiopia
and i have to just follow your
instruction in i'm hurry that's the
rules i can teach you how to count to
five yes and and pulette fletch sauced
sauce
don't worry
i'll give you sauced lifelines the first
one
you can google it lifeline roulette is
i'll give you this or that okay so one
correct instruction and one wrong
instruction you'll have to pick well
halfway if i pick wrong one that's what
you get
so staying at lifeline is i'm lost and
then i'll give you the instructions in
english i'm a host
already wait like i don't want to use it
one cup yeah no i don't know
i
like no idea and lentil takes a long
time so i thought it was the first thing
you have to do
is
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we use red onion and like pretty much
every dish in ethiopia and your house
smells like red onions all the time
if you're gonna go out and your mom is
cooking ethiopian food like you want to
shower and exit the house otherwise
you'll just like smell like red
okay like i want to say slow down but
like even you throw down i have no idea
yeah okay
okay she's smiling so i think it's good
how much do we use and and okay it is
what do you think that means is she
hurry hurry
it's like okay okay okay
[Laughter]
i was just like lost you're saying like
you are on you are you are good
like i'm not onion
okay
yeah
go bad
vegetable left
it's this it sounds more like garlic i
think this is also means like same size
as i don't know let's go about me go
back is like good job like you're doing
it like if you get an a and you come
home and your mom will be like go best
go guys
[Laughter]
i like spicy but i don't like too spicy
as soon but um
i'm not a bit spicy
okay
yes
yes
i think you have to cook this i don't
know so we need one more media
do you want to use one of your lifelines
yes
okay which one
this or that the instruction i gave you
okay means you can use that pan or
another pan oh
okay so i literally see that one
i feel like i wasted a life long it's
okay
now you know a new word
how about this one how do you call it
soon
do you need a two pounds
[Laughter]
how did you know because i speak
oh got it got it okay two tablespoons
hang out there
tablespoon
[Music]
two tablespoons
of chocolate red onion first perfect and
saute okay how do you keep up your
language i lost my like ethiopian accent
so when i talk to people they don't
recognize it oh i talked to my mom my
sister
i only remember how to talk to women
because i don't really talk to men and
i'm alright and it's different oh and i
was like oh i'm so glad i'm like working
with reid because i was like if i was a
man i'd be butchering it
wait so how how is it different like
different it's like french or like
spanish like to a man
into a woman is different also to um an
older person or someone your age is
different it's like respect thing yeah
it's either we do have a gender
i'm going to saute for five minutes
until this is soft and tender nutrition
garlic and jalapeno saute until fragrant
that's what i guess i wasn't like i'm
not even speaking your gut you got it
cumin
[Music]
do you use a lot of cumin you're cooking
my house we do so every family has
different spice mixes but this is my
mom's way of making this different
people put different spices i think like
some people put cardamom also in
different like regions is different
spices this is the way my family makes
it okay
oh
[Laughter]
and sprinkle some cilantro
i should ask you soon i should come at
you set aside oh it's not end this is
not a dish
okay we're just getting started
no play okay
[Music]
which one would you like google can you
google ducat
no
[Laughter]
um
i'm going to just cut it and
if it's wrong she will you know
go balls
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm going to use my last lifeline
because i'm almost there
[Music]
please show me okay how i do it yeah you
cut it in like threes
oh
okay
and then you double line it
or like twos i guess two and a half i'll
show you how to fold it so you fold it
like this and then you fold this one
like this
and then you stuff it
and then you fold this back into there
god blush understood
goodbye okay i've never seen the
technique before like i actually like
how you're doing it too
maybe it's easier
maybe you can make some that way yeah
but i like i'm gonna follow yours okay
and you are going to staff
where here i don't know yeah
usually a lot of people do it like it's
not a one-person job we'll just sit and
like go fold it together i feel like i'm
the slowest person
that's the glue glue
i don't know this is mostly skin
i don't know
isn't it too flat though i'm going to
try a few more and until i get it right
okay
look how much progress i made wow
like almost no feeling this is my first
try and now i know how to stuff go best
gumballs
i don't know
okay
set aside
i think we have to fry right we do in
oil
sauce
degree sauce metal hamsa sauced
sauced metal hamsa
375 that's 365 350 350.
i'm sorry
we're gonna wait until this reaches 3
50. yeah but you have to say 3 15 in a
mark sauce
metal
metal
hamsa hamsa sauce meadow samsa high five
okay um it's 350.
okay
like three
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
no i think mimi is popular but my
grandmother called me meemo when i was
little and then it stayed that's
actually not my real name oh what's your
real name it's bamnet bemnet
in real name but we have house names and
my house name was mimo oh because it's
like my mimi my little girl like
it's kind of nickname yeah but then it's
like now my my actual name it's normal
for little lentils to come out
all right
i'll go get mine okay you want to
compare yes all right i'll be back yay
are you ready yes
oh you're so pretty
you did really good thank you i'm
impressed i think i did great
i had no idea what she was talking about
but i did my best i'm excited it looks
crunchy let's try yours first all right
i'm going to try this one yes
[Music]
it's good so good are you going to be
making this yeah
it was easy if it was english or
japanese yeah for sure and this is
vegetarian yeah it is we we usually make
it with lentils other cultures make it
with ground beef
so we call this an ethiopia sambusa
sambusa it almost sounds like samosa i
don't know where the translation got
lost but we pronounce it sambusa but
it's the same as samosa
you want to try mine yeah let's try it
let's do it so cute
i like yours filled a lot of feeling
like i was struggling putting you know
like feeling inside but yeah
most of the time you learn how to make
this when you're little because it's a
family activity
and your mom would be like frying it and
the kids would be folding it so i've
been doing this since i was very little
oh wow but you're getting started now so
one day
yours will be as fluffy as mine
yes thank you so much for teaching me
amharak and thank you so much for
teaching me how to cook sambusa you're
so welcome thanks for learning
thank you and thank you guys following
my journey
ciao
oh yes
[Music]
you